ces derniers jours la presse s'est fait
l'écho d'un appel de détresse lancé par
l'animateur et producteur patrice
laffont star de la télé dans les années
90 patrice laffont était omniprésent sur
le petit écran à la tête de plusieurs
jeux cultes comme des chiffres et des
lettres
mais la mènerai messieurs bonsoir mon
fort boyard ou encore pires amis voilà
un bon jour s'il a disparu de la
circulation médiatique il ya plusieurs
années de cela l'homme revient
aujourd'hui pour expliquer la situation
financière compliquée dans laquelle il
se trouve
je suis une cigale j'ai tout dépensé je
ne suis pas dans la mouise mais si je
vis encore quelques années je vais avoir
une fin de vie assez difficile
pécuniairement parlant une déclaration
qui peut paraître surprenante de la part
d'un animateur qui durant plusieurs
années à toucher de gros salaires dont
les années fastes de la télévision et
dans la catégorie des stars qui évoquent
leurs problèmes dans la presse patrice
laffont n'est pas tout à fait un cas
isolé
ces dernières années de nombreux people
ont également pris la parole dans les
médias pour parler de leurs problèmes
d'argent on pense bien sûr à ophélie
winter qui avait évoqué dans plusieurs
médias sa situation très précaire ou
encore lio il ya deux ans qui avait
avoué être endetté alors selon vous les
stars ruiné ont-elles raison de se
plaindre
alors oui ou non vous agissez là dessus
il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
réactions sur cela benjamin castaldi nom
est ce que vous êtes déjà plein vous
souhaitez vous avez des difficultés
expliqué qui m'était arrivé mais serena
ont été escroqués donc c'est autre chose
c'est un autre débat
wen façon que j'ai compris trop tard
qu'il fallait pas dire ce qu'on gagne et
pour mieux en gagner on dit pas qu'on a
plus d'argent parce que pour les gens et
c'est tout à fait normal quand on est la
télévision quand on passe pendant 10 ans
20 ans on gagne de l'argent donc si on
dit on n'a plus d'argent 13 du mois vous
on va vous dire enfin quand même il a
gagné 10 x 20 x 30 x 50 vols explique
pourquoi il se plaint même s'il a
sûrement des problèmes
je pense que pour lyon ça n'est pas
audible je pense si une erreur de faire
payer pour ça après ça peut arriver
parce que malheureusement un super mec
pas très c'est un super mec
après je vous le dis ça c'est la vérité
quand on décroche financièrement c'est
qu'une question de niveau on peut
décrocher avec 1000 euros par mois comme
avec 100000 euros par mois c'est qu'une
question de proportions mais les gens
peuvent pas comprendre et c'est normal
c'est normal qu'on pleure avec 100000
euros par exprès je prendrais bien sûr
rien voilà on est en revanche je pense
qu'il a tort de se plaindre parce
qu'effectivement il faut que ce n'est
pas vrai audible voilà c'est horrible
alors vous pensez qu'il a raison de se
plaindre
guillaume genton je pense que les stars
ils gagnent beaucoup d'argent à mon avis
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est quelle
train de vie qui va avec apple entourage
qui leur prend beaucoup d'argent il ya
des déplacements et des avions et voyage
offert à des soirées en boîte de nuit
nos ça explique un peu le fait qu'elle
jouera ariane se retrouve sur la base
sont plus ou moins je les comprends un
peu quand même vous
vous avez l'air de douter des pauvres
parce que dans le sens où tu gagnes
beaucoup d'argent matu gère ta vie et tu
gères ton argent mais après tu vas pas
te plaindre
tu gagnes cent mille euros par mois et
après on va forcément bon quand ça nous
arrive je pense
ouais c'est ça il arrivera je pense que
lille on s'en rend belle à contenu mais
c'est vrai comment la cour qu'on le dise
ma poule explique meir a sonné mais le
bon sens même rigueur
gilles verdez la dignité c'est de se
taire il ya des gens qui souffrent et
hull et gilet jaune les gens modestes
qui gagnent 1000 euros par mois ils
peuvent pas entendre ça donc
effectivement c'est quelqu'un de très
bien mais là il a fait une erreur une
grave erreur d'en bas il faut dire la
vérité
patrice à poil a plus rien à perdre
voilà je vous le dis et patrice moi ce
que j'aime chez lui c'est qu'il n'est
pas langue de bois où ils sont trente
vérité il dit l'arbre il a un il a un
vrai rempart et oui pourquoi on doit
aborder fois une fois de plus ils ne
font que répondre à des questions et on
leur reproche d'avoir répondu à des
questions ça faut savoir ce qu'on veut
et puis ensuite ils ne gagnent pas
toujours cent mille neuf cent mille
euros par mois et puis aussi du stade du
ray milland ya des gens qui restent deux
fois quinze ans sans travailler même si
tu as gagné beaucoup d'argent par une
courbe pendant une courte période et une
période où ça peut être un marasme
effectivement souvent ils ont
l'entourage qui vivent pape alors frappe
à leurs crochets mais en fait on va pas
il ne se plaint pas au sens strict il
dit simplement il répond à une question
il dit simplement qu'il a tout dépensé
il est pas à la recherche d'un de 2 dont
il élimine ne fait pas une communication
publique pour dire écoutez et des mois
alors raymond bailly la droite et la
droite se plaindre en tout cas ils ont
tous le droit de se plaindre sauf que
moi je vais pas les plaindre parce que
c'est ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
c'est benjamin il a bien dit ont pressé
proportionnelle et je pense qu'ils
perdent pied parce qu'à un moment donné
ils s'achètent des porsche qui
s'achètent des ferrari s'est déjà doit
selon fars de ceux qui se plaignent pour
gagner beaucoup d'argent je parle pas
d'un mec qui a gagné un peu d'argent
dans sa vie je parle de quelqu'un qui a
bien réussi sa vie qui a gagné beaucoup
d'argent les années 80 90 quand tu dis
moi si je travaille 40 ans de ma vie au
final j'ai gagné six ans entre 600 et
700 mille euros dans toute ma vie eu des
fois ils ont des cachets de 5 millions 6
millions alors ils ont décidé d'acheter
des villas dans le sud c'est très bien
on n'est pas jaloux ils ont décidé
d'acheter des appartements au pied de la
tour eiffel on n'est pas jaloux on n'est
pas jaloux de tout ça tant mieux si tu
acheté un appartement à tour eiffel 6 es
tu arrives à 70 ans et que tu me dis oh
la la c'est dommage j'ai pu rien je suis
fauché oui mais tu as vécu pendant 70
ans a fait quatre fois le temps du monde
tu as été heureux c'était un choix de
vie tant mieux je suis pas jaloux mais
moi je ne me plaindrai ja mais qui m'a
pas demandé les plays offs
était pas vraiment en train de se
plaindre effectivement par match soit la
tristesse générale en général en général
oui d'accord
enfin il est en train de répondre à une
question sur sa situation financière oui
on peut tous avoir des revers de
fortunes quelle que soit l'échelle et
puis effectivement c'est des gens qui
sont dans des tranches d'imposition qui
sont surréalistes de temps en temps ces
gens que vous pourrez avoir des contrats
ou on gagne très bien ma vie pendant un
certain temps et après on se retrouve
complètement à la rue parce que
effectivement ou parce que ça perdu pied
il l'a dit benjamin tout le monde
aimerait bien payer beaucoup d'impôts et
aux pays-bas possebon gagnent beaucoup
d'argent au monde à vrai dire bibou
d'impôts on va juste devoir dans le
cadre de la télé c'est des gars qui font
dix vingt trente ans après les comédiens
qui font un film et plus pendant trois
ans paraît las c'est désolant eux ils
sont à l'antenne depuis 30 40 ans mais
ne peuvent pas entendre qu'un gars qui
est là depuis 40 ans et des problèmes
maintenant il peut en avoir et c'est
tout à fait possible et bien sûr qu'ils
quittaient donc oui mais qu'est ce que
vous avez vu où vous avez vu chez jean
marc morandini vous évoquez peut-être
des petites difficultés financières ses
tics c'était quoi chez jean-marc donc
c'est très local c'est très local mais
mais mais pour revenir à à cette affaire
deux des stars entre guillemets qui sont
désargentés moi je crois que ça met fin
justement ce genre de déclarations à une
illusion qui consiste à associer
immédiatement la célébrité à l'argent
l'argent exactement et c'est pas vrai
parce que en effet on voit bien patrice
et d'autres sont en difficulté ce sont
les difficultés qui peuvent faire
provisoire qui peuvent durer mais en
tout cas ça mais face à cette illusion
non ceux qui n'ont que ceux qui sont
célèbres n'ont pas forcément beaucoup
d'argent devant que jean mi oui enfin et
je vois pas d etat d exemple les gens
qui sont célèbres gens ils sont tous un
moment de leur vie blindés donc c'est
après s'ils ont mal géré l'argent sa
famille qui s'élève à wim et maintenant
de quand tu es quand tu réussite
l'argent on en regarde je vais être
encore plus violent et je devrais pas
dire ça
il ya des gens qui ont été chroniqueur
ici chroniqueur ils sont venus ils sont
partis et peut-être même encore ici ils
ont gagné juste et perpétuent leur a
donné 40 ans d'une vie en salaire je me
suis amusé à le calculer les quarante
ans d'une vous donc là prennent le
dessus moi j'ai un chroniqueur de tpm
paix demain qui vient me dire papa de
pala un papa ce soir à ceux qui sont
partis peut-être qui vient me dire je
suis malheureux j'ai plus d'argent mais
je moi je fais pas le plein de non plus
ça marche pour tout ça marche aussi pour
un chroniqueur ça marche aussi pour un
comédien faut bien se rendre compte de
la valeur de l'argent qu'ils ont touché
alors ils auront le mode de vie qui va
avec et c'est tant mieux ils ont été
heureux et on est
ben je ne sais je connais les salaires
il a raison je connais les salaires sans
visas visent une île aux rotules
multiplient 18000 euros par type lice
sur les séries c'est facile c'est très
simple à calculer mais raymond moi je
suis un peu d'accord avec lui elle est à
vous je vous le dis est ce qu'on peut
voir oui à 11% le nom a cassé en fin de
course et ça résume vers ce que disait
raymond je suis assez d'accord avec toi
mon raymond